[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Christian Sievers ich sage guten Abend
und begrüße Sie ganz herzlich bei uns
gemeinsam mit Katja streesow für den
Sport auch von mir einen schönen guten
Abend und dann gucken wir auf unsere
wichtigsten Themen an diesem
Freitagabend
Endspurt vor der Bundestagswahl die
Parteien werben bei ihren
abschlusskundgebungen ein letztes Mal um
Stimmen
weltweiter Protesttag für den
Klimaschutz allein in Deutschland bringt
Fridays for future Zehntausende auf die
Straße
umstrittene Entscheidung des Papstes der
Kölner Erzbischof Wölki bleibt im Amt
nimmt aber erst einmal eine Auszeit
[Musik]
es ist für die Parteien heute der
Abschluss eines langen und aufreibenden
Wahlkampfs übermorgen ist Bundestagswahl
und davor gibt es jetzt eine letzte
Umfrage vom ZDF Politbarometer vom
späten Abend gestern die wir uns zu
Beginn dieser Sendung mal anschauen und
die sieht erstmal im vorderen Teil so
aus in der Sonntagsfrage käme die SPD
unverändert auf 25 Prozent die Union
legt zu auf 23 Prozent plus 1 die Grünen
würden leicht verbessert bei 16,5%
landen die Kanzlerkandidatin und
Kandidatinnen dieser Parteien werben
auch heute um die Stimmen der
unentschlossenen
Salutschüsse der Gebirgsschützen in
München für CDU und CSU die sich heute
in demonstrativer Einigkeit zeigen
Kandidat Armin Laschet kämpft zwei
Prozentpunkte liegt die Union laut
Umfragen hinter der SPD Angriff auf die
Sozialdemokraten sie fangen wieder an
mit ihren alten sozialistischen schöpfen
der 80er Jahre Bürokratie Steuererhöhung
Leute bevormunden ihnen vorschreiben wie
sie zu reden haben nein wir haben
selbstständige Bürger die wissen das
besser als diese Ideologien
selbstbewusst der Auftritt der SPD ihr
Kandidat zog an Union und Grünen seit
dem Sommer vorbei Olaf Scholz spürt sagt
er heute die Leute wollten einen
Aufbruch seine Rede stellt er unter das
Leid Thema Solidarität und Zusammenhalt
wer jetzt die cdu/csu und auch die FDP
in dieser Lage vorschlägt dass Leute wie
ich oder Leute die noch mehr verdienen
als ein Bundesminister jetzt mal
dringend eine Steuersenkung brauchen
dass das 30 Milliarden Euro im Jahr
kosten darf der kann nicht rechnen der
versteht nichts von Finanzen aber der
handelt auch unsolidarisch eine
Kanzlerin Annalena baerburg das ist seit
dem Absturz der Grünen in den Umfragen
wohl illusorisch mitregieren aber könnte
drin sein ihre Abschlussrede widmet
bärbock ganz dem urthema der Grünen der
Klimawende
der SPD Liebe Union die Leute sind nicht
blöd klimakanzlauf Plakate zu schreiben
reicht nicht aus wir können uns keine
halben Sachen mehr leisten es braucht
jetzt endlich eine Klima Bundesregierung
aus voller Kraft aus ganzem Herzen und
mit voller Leidenschaft der Wahlkampf
der drei Kanzlerkandidaten ist offiziell
beendet übermorgen haben die Wähler das
Wort
die Ergebnisse der kleineren Parteien
könnten auch wichtig sein wenn es um
künftige Koalitionsoptionen geht gucken
wir auch hier mal drauf die FDP liegt in
der letzten Umfrage nach wie vor bei 11
Prozent die AFD verliert einen Punkt auf
zehn Prozent die Linke bleibt bei 6%.
auch diese Parteien sind im Schluss
Sport und darüber berichtet Karl
Hinterleitner
die AFD versucht zum Abschluss noch
einmal zu mobilisieren und zu
polarisieren gegen die corona-politik
gegen einwanderungs- und Europapolitik
gegen alle anderen Parteien wir sind die
einzige
Oppositionskraft im Deutschen Bundestag
und natürlich tut das weh und ich kann
euch sagen wir werden stärker
im neuen Bundestag sein als bisher bei
der FDP ist der offizielle
Wahlkampfabschluss zwar erst morgen aber
auch die Liberalen sind auf der
Zielgeraden der Generalsekretär kämpft
noch einmal in Saarbrücken um Stimmen
der Vorsitzende und Spitzenkandidat in
Berlin wir wollen stark zweistellig
werden ich glaube wir haben eine Chance
den Abstand zu den Grünen zu verkürzen
weil die Menschen wissen dass Rennen um
Platz 3 ist mindestens so wichtig wie
das um Platz 1 wenn es um Koalitionen
geht
und auf dem Berliner Alexanderplatz
versucht heute auch die Linke die
letzten Unentschlossenen zu überzeugen
die Spitzenkandidatin kämpferisch für
ein breites Linksbündnis
wenn die SPD und die Grünen ihre
Wahlkampagne und ihre Versprechen ernst
nehmen dann geht das doch nicht mit der
FDP und auch nicht mit der Union das ist
doch wieder nur eine Ausrede vier Jahre
lang das eigene Programm nicht
durchsetzen zu müssen Politikwechsel
gibt es nur mit der Partei DIE LINKE
Ende des Wahlkampfs von drei Parteien
wie sie unterschiedlicher nicht sein
könnten zwei davon FDP oder linke haben
vielleicht die Chance das Land bald mit
zu regieren
aufhorchen lässt heute dass die EU
unmittelbar vor der Bundestagswahl
Russland Cyberangriffe vorwirft gegen
demokratische Institutionen in mehreren
Mitgliedsstaaten sei versucht worden
Daten von Abgeordneten und
Regierungsbeamten zu stehlen namentlich
genannt wird eine Hackergruppe namens
Ghostwriter die dem russischen
Militärgeheimdienst zugeordnet wird vor
diesem Hintergrund
in Berlin wie sicher ist denn die Wahl
am Sonntag also gänzlich ausschließen
lassen sich weitere Attacken oder
versuchte Attacken aus dem Netz
natürlich nicht das gehört schlicht zur
allgemeinen Bedrohungslage mittlerweile
bei demokratischen Wahlen das kennt man
aus anderen europäischen Ländern aber
der Bundeswahlleiter hat noch einmal
betont er sieht keine akute Gefahr für
die Bundestagswahl sein Haus sei gut
aufgestellt gegen weitere Cyberangriffe
und auch der Regierungssprecher Steffen
Seibert sagte heute noch einmal die
ordnungsgemäße Durchführung der Wahl sei
nicht gefährdet perfide ist allerdings
bei dieser Art von Angriffen dass sie
gar keinen echten idealen Schaden
anrichten müssen gar nicht erfolgreich
sein müssen weil beim Versuch Daten
abzufischen oder Daten zu manipulieren
es reicht schon wenn Sie Zweifel an den
Wahlen wecken denn in einer Demokratie
geht es sehr viel um Vertrauen vor allem
wenn es um die Frage geht zählt meine
Stimme wirklich wird sie korrekt gezählt
und da ist der Schaden eben schon
angerichtet wenn sich Verunsicherung
breit macht so gesehen muss man dieses
Problem sicherlich ernst nehmen wichtige
Hintergründe aller Dankeschön dafür
nicht nur im deutschen Wahlkampf ist die
Klimakrise eines der wichtigsten Themen
weltweit gingen heute hunderttausende
klimaaktivistinnen und Aktivisten auf
die Straßen die Bewegung Fridays for
future hatte aufgerufen zum achten
weltweiten Protesttag mit Kundgebungen
wie hier in Rom oder in Neu-Delhi allein
in Deutschland gab es gut 450 Aktionen
im Mittelpunkt dabei Berlin mehrere
10.000 Demonstranten angeführt wurde der
Protest dort von Greta Thunberg Stefanie
Hein berichtet
[Applaus]
Greta Thunberg beim ersten großen
klimastreik seit Corona denn die
Klimakrise sei nicht verschwunden
ein riesen
extrem wir haben extreme
Wetterereignisse rund um die Welt
gesehen die viele Leben gekostet haben
nicht zuletzt hier in Deutschland und
wenn die Pandemie uns eins gezeigt hat
dann dass die Klimakrise nie wie ein
wirklicher Notfall behandelt wurde
10.000 es sind zwei Tage vor der Wahl
vor den Deutschen Bundestag gekommen
weil ihnen die klimapläne der Parteien
nicht weit genug gehen Greta Thunberg
betont im ZDF wie wichtig die Wahl ist
Deutschland hat großen internationalen
Einfluss und ist so ein großer
Verschmutzer deshalb ist es eine
besonders wichtige Wahl mit Folgen für
zukünftige Generationen und die jetzige
auch
für die Einhaltung des Pariser
klimaschutzabkommens und die Begrenzung
der Erderwärmung auf 1,5 Grad ziehen sie
durch die Mitte der Hauptstadt
es ist wichtig hier zu sein weil da
leider von den Parteien nicht wirklich
die Klimaziele eingehalten werden wollen
einfach auch später wenn ich
älter bin 50 60 Jahren noch eine schöne
Welt haben möchte wir haben nur ein
Planeten und alles andere müsste
eigentlich hinten anstehen weil wenn wir
kein Planeten haben dann bringt es auch
nicht eine gute Wirtschaft zu haben sie
wollen so laut sein dass die Politik sie
hört
wer immer dieses Land künftig regiert
für den Bundespräsidenten steht fest die
deutschen müssten mehr tun für die
eigene Sicherheit und die Stabilität in
der Nachbarschaft und weltweit
Frank-Walter Steinmeier redete vor der
UNO Vollversammlung auch Europa ins
Gewissen es müsste aktiver werden mit
einer starken gemeinsamen außen und
Sicherheitspolitik aus New York
berichtet Johannes Hanau
er kam zwei Tage vor der Bundestagswahl
um der Welt zu versichern dass
Deutschland auch nach der Ehre Angela
Merkel seine internationale
Verantwortung wahrnehmen werde aber es
war vor allem auch eine Rede Richtung
Deutschland so kurz vor der Wahl zu
Beginn eine Analyse in schonungsloser
Offenheit aus dem Scheitern wie er es
nach den Afghanistan müsse Deutschland
Lehren ziehen wir müssen ehrlich sein im
Blick auf unsere Möglichkeiten
und auch auf die Grenzen dieser
Möglichkeiten wir müssen realistischer
sein in der Definition und Priorisierung
unserer Ziele und Interessen
oftmals meine Damen und Herren können
wir mehr erreichen
wenn wir weniger wollen
in einer Zeit in der die USA ihren
außenpolitischen Fokus nach Asien
richten müsse sich Deutsch und
europäische Außenpolitik verändern
Deutschland europäische Außenpolitik
darf sich nicht aufs recht haben und
verurteilen beschränken sondern
wir müssen unseren instrumentenkassen
erweitern
diplomatisch militärisch
Zivil humanitär weniger
Sendungsbewusstsein und Wunschdenken
mehr Pragmatismus und Realpolitik hat
Frank-Walter Steinmeier hier heute
gefordert nach dem Scheitern in
Afghanistan und der Umorientierung
Amerikas Richtung Asien müssten
Deutschland und Europa mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen auch
militärisch eine klare Mahnung an die
Wahlsiege am Sonntag und eine mögliche
Koalition nur ein auch militärisch
starkes Europa so die Botschaft des
Bundespräsidenten seine Außenpolitik an
der sich veränderten Realität ausrichtet
könne seine Interessen in Zukunft
selbstbewusst vertreten
und jetzt in der Sendung geht es um die
Krise im größten deutschen Bistum der
katholischen Kirche in Köln dort wird
der hochumstrittene Erzbischof Rainer
Maria Woelki sein Amt behalten das hat
der Papst entschieden Wölki habe im
Umgang mit dem Missbrauchskandal nicht
rechtswidrig gehandelt aber schwere
Fehler in der Kommunikation gemacht er
bleibe im Amt werde aber eine längere
Auszeit nehmen sagte Woelki heute der
Kardinal war stark in die Kritik geraten
nachdem er einen Gutachten über den
jahrzehntelangen sexuellen Missbrauch
nicht hatte veröffentlichen wollen
und dann müssen wir noch mal reden mit
Jürgen Erbacher aus unserer
zdf-kirchenredaktion Jürgen guten Abend
guten Abend also der Kardinal bleibt im
Amt nimmt aber eine Auszeit was sollen
die Betroffenen die Gläubigen denn
daraus jetzt machen also einerseits
schafft der Vatikan damit Klarheit und
sagt in Bezug auf die Missbrauchsfälle
im Umgang gibt es kein rechtswidriges
Verhalten des Kardinals andererseits
sieht der Vatikan ganz klar die
Situation ist Verfahren irgendwie muss
ein cut her und da kommt dem ROM ganz
gelegen dass der Kardinal sagt ich
möchte gerne Auszeit nehmen man möchte
also dass die Wogen sich ein bisschen
glätten allerdings gibt es viel Kritik
an dieser Entscheidung gerade von
Betroffenen sexualisierter Gewalt die
sich ein klareres nein auch das Vatikans
gegenüber dem Kardinal gewünscht hätten
selbst der Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz scheint skeptisch das
innerhalb dieser fünf Monate Auszeit
sich jetzt die Situation so grundlegend
verändern kann dass am Ende wieder ein
Neustart möglich ist ist denn
vorstellbar dass nach der Auszeit
plötzlich alles wieder players in Köln
nein es muss sich dann erst zeigen ob
der Kardinal und die Gläubigen sich
aufeinander zu bewegen und so dann eine
Versöhnung und eine Erneuerung wie es
heute im Vatikan schreiben heißt möglich
ist wenn das nicht der Fall ist dann
wird der Vatikan der Papst neu
entscheiden müssen und dann könnte auch
der heutige Tag trotz der klaren
Rückendeckung Roms gegenüber Wölki
könnte dieser Vorgang doch ein Rücktritt
auf Raten sein sagt Jürgen herbach
herzlichen Dank für diese Hintergründe
heute Abend
und jetzt bei uns das Thema Corona und
da bleibt die Ständige Impfkommission
zurückhaltend wenn es um eine dritte
Impfung geht in ihren aktualisierten
Empfehlungen rät sie nur Menschen mit
einem geschwächten Immunsystem zu einer
Auffrischung des Schutzes für alle
übrigen werden weitere Studienergebnisse
ausgewertet die coronazahlen in
Deutschland gehen weiter zurück das
Robert-Koch-Institut meldet
9.727 Neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24
Stunden und damit
1295 weniger als vor einer Woche 65
Todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben Tage
Inzidenz sinkt auf
62,5
515 weitere infizierte mussten seit
gestern ins Krankenhaus die
hospitalisierungsrate liegt aktuell bei
1,58
unser nächstes Thema in Großbritannien
wo ja der brexit bereits für Lücken in
den Supermarktregalen gesorgt hatte gibt
es jetzt neue Versorgungsprobleme und
die sind massiv
Beispiel Gas um
250 Prozent verteuerte sich der
Einkaufspreis seit Jahresbeginn auf
Millionen Kunden kommen jetzt extreme
Erhöhungen zu Beispiel Benzin weil seit
dem brexit-lkw-fahrer sind können nicht
mehr alle Tankstellen beliefert werden
Andreas Stamm berichtet
spritsuche statt Spazierfahrt an einigen
Tankstellen in England mühen sich
verzweifelte vergeblich ich bin
geschockt wie soll ich zur Arbeit kommen
meine Frau ist im 9 Monat schwanger es
dürfte jede Minute losgehen und ich
könnte ohne Sprit liegen bleiben die
Regierung warnt vor Hamsterkäufen doch
selbst an Orten ohne Engpässe wird es
eng
total verrückt einer kriegt Panik und
dann alle hinterher es gibt genug Sprit
in den Tanklagern aber nicht genug die
ihn ausliefern können denn im Land
fehlen 100.000 Lkw-Fahrer 10.000de
Prüfungen fielen wegen Corona aus bis zu
30.000 Fahrer aus der EU hat der brexit
vertrieben Spritmangel das neueste
Kapitel in Sachen Versorgungsprobleme
Fast Food Restaurants gehen Produkte aus
müssen Filialen schließen lückenhafte
einkaufsregale sind Alltag geworden
Supermarktketten jagen Fahrer per SMS
mit Boni oder gar doppelten Jahresgehalt
du wolltest gerade macht die Runde das
einige noch eine 6 Euro Einmalzahlung
drauflegen um Fahrer abzuwerben
anderer Treibstoff nächstes
Versorgungsproblem Gas der Einkaufspreis
ist in diesem Jahr umfasst das Dreifache
gestiegen Europarekord seit dem brexit
ist das Land nicht mehr Teil des
europäischen Energiemarkts der
Preissprünge abfedern hilft mehrere
Versorger sind pleite 1,5 Millionen
Haushalten drohen akut höhere Preise die
Regierung sucht nach Lösungen räumt aber
ein der Winter werde ungemütlich
nach dem Vulkanausbruch will Spanien La
Palma zum Katastrophengebiet erklären
die Kanareninsel brauche jetzt
umfassende Hilfe und einen
Wiederaufbauplan sagt Regierungschef
Pedro Sanchez die inselbehörden
evakuierten heute weitere Orte weil der
Vulkan wieder mehr Gas und Asche
ausstößt hunderte Gebäude hat die Lava
in den letzten Tagen bereits begraben
aber sie verschonte dieses eine Haus
hier wie eine Insel inmitten der
Zerstörung genannt wird es jetzt das
Wunderhaus von La Palma
was für ein Bild jetzt hat Katja den
Sport für uns ja und es geht rasant los
denn der Formel 1 Circus dreht an diesem
Wochenende in Russland seine Runden
heute die ersten freien Trainings in
Sotschi in denen Mercedes pilot-walterie
Bottas der Schnellste war beim WM
führenden Max Verstappen wurde heute
schon klar dass er am Sonntag aus der
letzten Startreihe starten wird
durch den Wechsel auf den vierten Motor
nur drei sind erlaubt wird Verstappen am
Sonntag in die letzte Startreihe
verbannt sein schärfster Rivale
Weltmeister Louis Hamilton dagegen rast
mit seinem Mercedes Nummer 44 bis auf
44.000stel heran an Teamkollege Walter
Reporters der auf der 5,8 km langen
Strecke die schnellste Runde fährt auf
dem Kurs zwischen den Olympiastätten von
2014 gelingt auch Sebastian Vettel ein
ordentlicher Auftakt die neuen beste
Trainingszeit im ersten Martin Mercedes
bleibt Top-Favorit in Sotschi muss nur
aufpassen dass die eigene Crew auf den
Beinen bleibt
bei der Vielseitigkeit cm in avenge in
der Schweiz greifen die deutschen Reiter
nach Medaillen ingrid Klimke und Ihr
Pferd Hale Bob führen in der
Einzelwertung nach der Dressur und in
der Mannschaftswertung hat sich die
deutsche Equip von Platz 3 auf 2
verbessert morgen gibt es den
geländeritz Sonntag dann die
Entscheidung im Springreiten
und in der Basketball-Bundesliga gab es
gleich zum Auftakt einen Spitzenspiel
und eine Überraschung der Meister Alba
Berlin verloren eigene Halle gegen die
Telekom Baskets aus Bonn
die Bonner liefern ein starkes Stück ab
erst sitzt sie hinten dann wirbelt
Parker Jackson Cartwright genannt pjc
unterm Berliner Korb die Gäste holen
eine 13 Punkte Rückstand auf und gehen
kurz vor Ende des dritten Viertels durch
pjc erstmals in Führung der 180 Mann ist
mit 25 Punkten bester Spieler auf den
Parkett Bonn gewinnt 88 zu 86 auch weil
alba-kapitän luxic Bar kurz vor Schluss
ein ungenaues Zuspiel fabriziert es ist
der erste Bonner Sieg in Berlin seit
Zeit wurde es würden die Bonner sagen
wir das bestimmt bestimmt auf jeden Fall
kann man an den Katja vielen Dank gerne
so ich habe jetzt noch das
Wochenendwetter für Sie das kommt mit
dickem Ende am Sonntag Katja Honnefer
hat Schauer und Gewitter in der
Vorhersage
um 22 Uhr habt hat aber erstmal der
Kollege Klaus Kleber das heute journal
wir sind morgen wieder für Sie da danken
für heute und vom ganzen Team hier
wünsche ich Ihnen einen sehr angenehmen
Freitag Abend tschüss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guten Abend zwischen dem hoch über dem
zentralen Mittelmeer und dem Tief über
Portugal kommt jetzt am Wochenende noch
mal Sommerduft zu uns aus südlichen
Gefilden über Norddeutschland allerdings
halten sich dichtere Wolken das ist eine
Schlappe Kaltfront mit der hatten wir es
auch heute zu tun und auch in der Nacht
bleibt es über Norddeutschland meist
bedeckt im Süden wird es dagegen klar
und unter dem klaren Sternenhimmel
sinken die Temperaturen auf einstellige
neun bis vier Grad unter den Wolken
bleibt es bei 16 bis 10 Grad deutlich
milder und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 18 Grad an
der Ostsee und maximal 27 Grad am
Oberrhein es gibt also häufig noch mal
Temperaturen über 20 Grad und doch
morgen bleibt es in diesem Streifen von
der Uckermark bis zum Emsland bedeckt an
den Küsten sehen sie häufiger mal die
Sonne und auch über den Mittelgebirgen
besonders strahlend sonnig wird es aber
in Süddeutschland
am Sonntag ändert sich alles denn von
Südwesten kommen kräftige Schauer und
Gewitter heran zunächst ein
Rheinland-Pfalz im Saarland und den
Baden-Württemberg bis zum Abend aber
auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen Hessen
Thüringen und Bayern im Nordosten
bekommen sie davon gar nichts mit da
kommen die Gewitter erst am Montag an
guten Abend